ينضم الينا رامي القلوب الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد رامي نبدا
بالتعهدات الرئيس
الروسي بواصله الحمله العسكريه في
اوكرانيا للقضاء على ما وصفها بالتهديدات
نظام النزيل الجدد القائم في اوكرانيا على
حد التعبير منذ انقلاب في عام 2014 ما هي
ملامح المرحله المقبله عسكريا وستراتيجيا
بالنسبه للرئيس الروسيه
هذه التصريحات اليوم بعد مرور عام مع
الحرب
اذا نظرنا الى نتائج الاستطلاعات الراي
فمنها مثلا مركز الافاده غير الحكومي
واقرا استطلان قبل بدء الحرب اظهر ان
69% من الروس يستحسنون اداء الرئيس بوتين
والان ارتفعت نسبه هؤلاء الى اكثر من 80%
باستثناء فتره قصيره تراجعت فيها الى دون
هذا الرقم اثناء عمليه التعبئه الجزئيه في
الخريف الماضي التي اغضبت كثيرا من الروس
الان روسيا شانها في ذلك شان غيرها من
الدول هي تتحكم في وسائل الاعلام
التلفزيونيه وهي الاكثر وصولا الى الراء
العام وحتى الان الوضع الاقتصادي لا يزال
يسمح
بان يقنع الراي العام لان هذه التضحيات في
سبيل مواجهه النيتو
منعه وصول المثليه الجنسيه الى روسيا وهذه
النقطه حتى تطرق اليها اليوم في خطابه
وكذلك وقت الخطاب ضم اربع مقاطعات الى
السياده الروسيه في نهايه سبتمبر الماضي
فحتى الان حتى اذا كان هناك احتجاج او رفض
داخلي في روسيا هو يقتصره على بعض الاوساط
الشبابيه
الخونه هل يقصد ذلك من يتعارض مع الحرب او
مع قرار الحرب
هذا المفهوم واسع جدا اعتقد ان المقصود به
هو من يروج لاخبار تصنفها روسيا كاذبه عن
اعمال الجيش الروسي وبالفعل قد صدرت عده
احكام بحق المعرضين الروس ومن هم مثلا
المعارضه الذي صدر في نهايه العام الماضي
حكم بالسجن لمده 8 سنوات ونصف العام
بالاضافه الى هناك من كثيرون غدروا البلاد
وان كانت روسيا غير قادره هل هناك نسبه
هناك من يعتبر ان عدد قليل هو من غادر
هناك من يعتبر ان جزء كبير يعني هل من
ارقام عن من هرب او من غادر البلاد لكي لا
يتم الزنجبيل يعني يتم استدعائه للجيش او
للحرب في اوكرانيا
في الواقع ليست هناك ارقام دقيقه ولكن
بيانات وزارات الداخليه في الدول المحيطه
بروسيا مثل كازاخستان وجورجيا تظهر ان
هؤلاء يبلغ عددهم بدا مئات الالاف وقد
يكون انخفض الى اقل من ذلك بعد عوده قسم
منهم الى روسيا بعض انتهاء التعبئه
الجزئيه فبالتالي عندما يبلغ عدد سكان
روسيا نحو 146 مليون نسمه فهذه النسبه من
المغادرين هي غير مؤثره في المشهد العام
وفق رؤيه السلطات الروسيه عندما تتحدث
روسيا عن تعليق المشاركه في معاهده نيو
ستارت هل يخيف ذلك ما معنى ذلك متى داعيات
قرار كهذا
بالفعل هذا ربما التصريح الابرز الذي صدر
من البوتين اليوم والموجه الى الخارجه
ففعليا روسيا تعتبره ان هذه المعاهده هي
تنطبق به على مراقبه الاسلحه الروسيه
الامريكيه ولكن هناك ايضا قوه نوويه اخرى
فروسيه تتساءل اذا كانت هذه الدول تشكل
تحالفا موحدا مع واشنطن فلماذا لا تخضع
لهذه الرقابه وهنا الحديث يجري عن تعليق
مشاركه روسيا وليس الانسحاب منها فبالتالي
هذا يعني انه يمكن الوصول الى صيغه او
اتفاقيه اخرى او العوده الى تطبيق هذه
الاتفاقيه بعد تعديل بعض الشروط لا ننسى
ان الولايات المتحده نفسها كانت تطالب
باشراق الصين في المعاهده نعم شكرا جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا لك